[Music]
we had been expecting this for weeks and
this is usually how it goes for the us
supreme court their tournaments in june
the rulings that have been pending are
issued and they come out a couple a week
and yesterday came the decision from the
u.s supreme court
that the ncaa's business model is
basically an anti-trust violation and
here's how it goes it's very simple
the ncaa is the group that oversees all
of the universities that are out there
that are competing
by recruiting
the best athletes to come play
typically basketball and football those
are the big sports where the money is
generated so the stakes are high to get
the best players
so
by putting a rule in place through this
governing body that all you can offer
officially not unofficially but all you
could officially offer is room board
tuition fees and snacks right
it operates as a price fixing for your
labor force of course you don't have
competition among these various
universities as to who's going to get
the best deal free enterprise goes out
the window it's gone
it's all set it's all fixed and it
becomes a violation of the antitrust law
so the opinion that came from justice
gorsuch yesterday 9-0 court
agreed that it was an anti-trust
violation i'd say a lot to you they have
an offer just off the bat 9-0 like you
now
there are there are plenty of 9-0
decisions because there's plenty of
things that are obvious but on something
that's even remotely controversial in
society yeah because there are plenty of
people who think it's fine and dandy to
not pay
college athletes
when there's controversy in society and
the court says 9-0 it's a message to
anyone who's on the wrong side of it hey
you're on the wrong side of it and
justice kavanaugh's concurring opinion
was great he took a flamethrower he
really to the model yeah i mean it's
because the the argument from the ncaa
is this chris
our fans prefer our our athletes to be
amateurs well first of all do they does
any fair-minded person
who understands how much money is being
generated by college sports say you know
what i only enjoy this because i know
the kids aren't getting paid who in the
health thinks that way
and who thinks that's a realistic
anyways i mean some of them are getting
paid and it's different and everything
like that but yeah i know you're right
it makes no sense it's absolutely you
know totally backwards it makes total no
sense at all so i'm with you there go
ahead
well and and here's the point
the case was very narrow it was a fight
over whether or not players who are
being recruited by these universities
could be offered
educational benefits beyond the
undergraduate experience and the room
tuition board like a laptop like
postgraduate
credits toward future education business
schools
right yeah other enhanced education
because we always say oh you get an
education well okay offer me more
than get me in the law school
undergraduate experience right yeah yeah
give me give me advanced tuition to law
school med school
all these other things different
research help whatever but you know
enhanced study guides that that aren't
part of the basic package whatever the
case may be sure the ncaa said no no so
that's what spawned this litigation
but the kavanaugh opinion
puts the ncaa on notice that the
floodgates are going to open chris
because
i assume
there will be a a wave
of lawsuits filed as soon as today if
they weren't filed yesterday attacking
everything about the ncaa's restriction
on full and free enterprise and
competition and let me tell you the most
obvious thing
because there are several states as of
next thursday july 1
that will allow
college athletes in those states to
begin
generating revenue for their names
images and likenesses florida texas just
two of them right and there's a concern
that it's going to be the wild west it's
going to be open season it's going to be
crazy and there's potential abuses
whatever the case may be but you know
what at the core think about the rule
the ncaa
in order to avoid a long overdue
reckoning arising from its refusal to
pay fair value for the labor that it
gets for these billion dollar
extracurricular activities beyond saying
none of the schools are allowed to pay
these kids there's a rule to preserve
amateur athletics right that they can't
even go out and market their own stuff
can't do anything that i have i can't i
can't sell
jerseys with my name on it i can't do
autographed shows i can't benefit even
though it doesn't cost you ncaa
university right i can't go out and make
that money even though they're
preserving even though they're going to
have a strong amateur yeah right even
though they have a spring game or a
scrimmage
right you know before the season starts
and they're gonna charge fans to come in
to watch that spring game or the
scrimmage and then they're gonna make
you as a player sit on a table after the
game's over and sign a thousand
autographs for those people to add to it
but you can't go out and get one dollar
for that autograph from anybody else
so sorry i had to just go i didn't mean
to interrupt you there but that used to
bother me to death when i was in college
uh and especially for some of the other
guys that didn't have the means i did or
the parents i did where i'd go man this
kid's got nothing he's sitting in a line
there's ten thousand people he's gonna
be here at eight o'clock tonight and
they're gonna give him a biscuit and a
hamburger and say good job and he's
gonna get to go
home that's blown up yeah right the the
the the plunger was pushed down on the
detonator yesterday and even though the
ruling was narrow justice kavanaugh put
the ncaa and its member institutions on
notice that you have liability and now
you can't say well we didn't know we
wanted to see how this case would turn
out and that's never an excuse anyway
they interpreted the law incorrectly
yeah and and this is the point that
people need to understand they have been
interpreting it incorrectly for decades
they have believed that this is an
acceptable business model and chris it
is stunning to me
that it took this long
for the issue
to finally be brought to light i mean
this is the ultimate good news bad news
the good news is the law finally caught
up with the corrupt business enterprise
which is the ncaa the bad news is it
took so long to do it right and i
remember thinking about 10 years ago
this isn't sustainable people are
starting to realize that that that this
isn't fair no to the kids there's too
much money flowing in it's not fair
they're going to have their reckoning
someday and i think the ncaa chris has
just been trying to run out the clock as
long as it could extend the clock not
run it out but extend the clock as long
as it could make as much money
delay for as many budget cycles as
possible having to worry about how we
pay these guys and and look at look at
how long it's taken and it's going to
take even longer they're going to
continue
to to cram money into their pockets that
otherwise would go to the players and uh
hopefully the reckoning comes quickly
and when it does hopefully
as much money as possible get shaken out
of the trees because it's wrong now it's
always been wrong and everyone knows
going forward it is wrong and hopefully
they'll do something about it and if
they don't let the floodgates open on
name image and likeness
that's the easiest
piece of litigation
your model is an antitrust violation how
can you justify not letting these kids
go out
and make money from their names images
and likenesses when it costs you nothing
how can you justify that it's insane
it's it's absolutely insane it's really
i mean you think about it it's all it's
cruel in a lot of ways it's a bunch of
group grown-ups colluding to make sure
young men and you know especially in the
football world most of them
african-american young men who don't get
compensated for what they do or their
talents in life or anything like that
and i know like listen there's always
that guy at yeah okay that went to the
nfl and he ended up getting compensated
and all that but there's for every one
of those guys on a team there's 10 other
guys who were nfl caliber or you know
something happened to where they got a
bad injury don't get to go to the nfl or
we're really an awesome piece of peace
or part of the college football team and
sold
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
jerseys and all that and they don't ever
get to go to the nfl or capitalize and i
know they get that
you know free education which is not
nearly uh is is you know what do i want
to say
tick for tack or whatever the same equal
to to what you know they're giving back
to the university it's just wrong and
there's no cap on any of these people in
the ncaa or the people that work at
these schools they continue to just make
more money and benefit more and more
every year and try to hold the athlete
down that way it makes no sense it's a
total abuse i mean it's it's it's
actually cruel in a lot of ways the more
and more you think about it about all
the big time athletes that have been
awesome in college football who never
got fairly compensated for what they did
for their schools or their conference or
anything like that
regardless of what category the player
falls in it's wrong if you are the
person who becomes the
player there right you should have been
that
star
you should have been making money right
at college if you're the guy who suffers
the gruesome injury like tyrone pro
throw from alabama in 2005 he had the
thiesman-esque injury that ended his
career he could have gone on and made a
lot of money in the nfl
part of the risk he took at alabama
resulted in his career ending he doesn't
get compensated or just the guys who
have no chance to play in the nfl but of
course our lord did the major college
programs with this idea that hey maybe
you can play the nfl come play here
maybe you go to the nfl they're they're
the guts of the machine
the stars don't get a chance to shine if
you don't have the other guys on the
field sure they should be compensated
too and and and there's so you know any
time you start getting the ncaa or those
who support the ncaa inexplicably on
this on the run they start throwing
furniture in your path oh how we're
going to do this or what about the
non-revenue sports well hey that's for
you to figure out you you've made all
this money over the years without paying
your players maybe you should have saved
some of it for the rainy day fund for
the reckoning that's coming when you
have to figure out how to make it all
work when you have to actually pay these
guys and chris something you said it
reminded me of one of the passages in
the kavanaugh concurring opinion and i
think it's worth repeating here
if i can find it here it is the bottom
line
is that the ncaa and its member colleges
are suppressing the pay of student
athletes who collectively generate
billions of dollars in revenue for
colleges every year those enormous sums
of money flow to seemingly everyone
except the student athletes
college presidents athletic directors
coaches conference commissioners and
ncaa executives take in six and
seven-figure salaries colleges build
lavish new facilities but the
student-athletes who generate the
revenue many of whom are
african-american and from lower-income
backgrounds ends up with little or
nothing
that's that's it in a nutshell
and that has been the fundamental truth
that the ncaa has been running from
for at least the last 10 years i mean i
i can imagine
the the meetings
pre-2000
where the people on the inside
understood the scam they were running
and they're sitting around smoking
cigars and laughing because no one has
figured it out can you believe we've
done this where we make all this money
and we don't have to pay our workers
what factory in america can operate
without paying its workers yeah they've
been getting away with it in plain sight
for decades chris that's why the
reckoning needs to come and when it
comes it needs to be and you got people
saying it's going to ruin there's not
going to be any more college football
there'll be college football as long as
it's generating billions in revenue yeah
there will be college football it will
survive
now where does it go though just that's
where i'm i'm curious just like your
take on that how long does this
all take to come into effect
when do schools and teams start to
you know
change the rules on their own a little
bit when does the nick saban start to go
i'm but i'm going to change here's your
scholarship offer and you're into the
alabama business school blah blah blah
like when when will that when we start
yeah
recruiting happens right now
you if now the kid has to know to ask
for it right and hopefully the word gets
out to the athletes and their families
that it's not just your undergraduate
education you can ask for more things
but but i look i think
every day that passes
where the ncaa doesn't completely reform
its business model what the ncaa is
hoping is that congress gets involved
and creates a federal law that the ncaa
can hide behind of course because
yesterday's ruling to me
says
all this stuff is illegal any rule that
you put in place to restrict the
benefits educational or financial for
someone that you want to come fuel your
multi-million dollar football machine
any restriction you put in place is an
antitrust violation and that's why i
think the first thing they should do
today
name image and likeness it's open season
and trust me it's going to be a
potential mess because what it does is
it allows the schools who have the
richest boosters to
you know give a guy yeah a position
where you you know you're selling his
jerseys
and you're losing a bunch of money
because you're paying him way more yeah
than what his jerseys are ever going to
sell for as a way to funnel cash to him
there will be abuses definitely but
that's okay
because the ultimate abuse is denying
the kids the opportunity to make any
money at all that's the ultimate abuse
there's nothing that anyone else can do
that's going to be worse than what the
ncaa has done for the last hundred years
yeah i agreed and like you know you know
who cares if that booster or whatever
decides to give a guy some job for
signing autographs and okay yeah he pays
him thousand dollars you know a few
thousand dollars in a summer to come
intern and over pays him a lot for a job
that yeah he just sat a desk and you
know answered a few emails but okay yeah
we paid him ten thousand dollars in july
and ten thousand dollars in august
before trinia who gives a damn like come
on move on with the world that's the way
the world works like you're talking
about in every other industry so you
know hopefully uh we'll start to see
some of some of the benefits of this new
ruling
they they could start to make their
recompense by giving reggie bush's
heisman back oh that would be the fam
tangible
because they get so caught up in these
stupid ass rules
that uh
and look guys have been getting come on
yeah i mean take everybody's heisman
away then i mean like almost like half
of them got to go because they've
there's been rules broken sorry
i mean you know the the the the two
tickets that you would get as a player
and you would sell to whoever for
whatever amount of money the person
wants to put in your hand that's been
going on forever right
they did that in texas yeah they've done
it everywhere that's where my point was
a few years ago when i made the comment
about hundred dollar handshakes and
everything it's going on everywhere it
doesn't matter like stop like just you
know get over it's going on at harvard
it's going on at usc it's going to texas
it's going on in michigan you can't stop
it okay but now we can maybe make it
more legitimate and actually really help
out players and their families and
everything like that
you know where it's not going on yeah
you know where it's not happening it's
not happening in the nfl because
everybody gets paid
see
when you pay the players a fair rate
no one else feels compelled
to give them a dime right they're being
compensated so the ncaa has benefited
from this it's been this like this weird
like they have to act like they care but
maybe they don't really care deep down
because it's allowed them to continue to
make all the money and keep all the
money right and pay the coaches the
multi-millions that they pay them but
that that's the oh at the core of this
you know anytime there's an issue like
this somebody's worried about their own
ox being gored and what's going to
happen is it's going to be harder to
justify all the money that goes to the
athletic directors the presidents
the uh the coaches it's going to be a
lot harder to justify the coaching staff
you know everybody's making six figures
on my 20-person staff and look at these
facilities look how great they are and
the the money will get redistributed but
however it gets redistributed it needs
to be distributed to
the people who are generating it it's a
basic fundamental truth and i think
yesterday's 9-0 ruling from the u.s
supreme court should put that issue to
rest now going forward we figure out how
best to do it and the ncaa has every
incentive to do it chris because they
continue to face liability if they don't
do it right and maybe the right way to
do it is just throw up on the floodgates
and let the schools offer whatever they
think their budgets will will support to
attract that great athlete who's going
to come to town and help them win a
national championship no i know i mean
i'd love to see that i would i'm
actually really interested to see kind
of the unintended consequences if things
did go that way too just what it would
do to college football
is it going to make like you know the
power school is even more powerful will
it make those top earning schools
dominate even more will the clemsons
alabama's ohio states of the world
because of this rule even get a stronger
hold on college football mike i mean
that's where i'm kind of interested with
all this stuff too the things to look
forward to down the line
one last point yeah
because the nfl does have limits on what
players can do by way of entering into
side deals specifically as it relates to
the spreading
sportsbook industry draftkings fanduel
bet mgm etc points bet
there's
there there's there's there are no such
limitations unless congress passes a law
or these various states pass this law
you could have even though the nfl
athletes are forbidden from having
sponsorship agreements with sportsbooks
college athletes
should be allowed to
because any restriction
on their ability to do so
is an antitrust violation and the only
reason the nfl can do it is they have a
union yeah and as part of that union
existence they're allowed to have these
anti-trust violations
and i don't think college wants to have
a union but that's the only way they're
going to be able to keep pandora inside
of her box chris that's always tough
because
with with with the antitrust laws it is
open season and it's going to be crazy
but you know what one way or the other
the people who deserve to make some
money are finally going to start making
some money
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports